Hey there smart less listeners, it's Kelly Rippa. Remember hearing that Matthew McConaughey and Woody Harrelson might be brothers or that Rob Lowe briefly had a fling with Demi Moore? Lucky Rob. You can hear it all and much more on my podcast, Let's Talk Off Camera with Kelly Rippa. Every Wednesday I get to ask the questions that I really want to know and talk to friends like Andy Cohen, Carol Burnett, Seth Meyers, Goldie Hawn, and so many more. It's fun, it's honest, and the best part, it's off camera. And believe me, that's when you get the good stuff. One of my favorite conversations was with the legendary Coleman Domingo. We talked about his longstanding friendship with Lenny Kravitz, his full circle moment with Oprah, and the
unbelievably romantic way Coleman met his now husband. Here's a little taste of that love story. So tell me the story about how you met your husband because it doesn't sound real. You know, because it doesn't feel real, to be honest. Tell me. First of all, we're celebrating our 10-year wedding anniversary in two days. Amazing. Thank you.
Thank you. But we met almost 20 years ago. Next year will be 20 years. We literally met in the Stone Ages of technology. And I say that because I was really minding my business. One night I was living, I lived in New York, but I went to Berkeley Rep to do a show. So on Sunday night, I decided to go to Walgreens to get a mask. I wanted to get like a Queen Helene mask
to like get my pores together. So I go in there and walking out of Walgreens was this beautiful, beautiful man with hair down past his shoulders and a lip piercing. And I was like, what? And he had the greenest eyes. I don't know, he just looked like something out of a fairy tale.
And we just locked eyes. And I was just awestruck by it. So then I came back outside. I didn't even go inside. I came back out. And I'm looking at him, he's looking at me. He's with this girl, and this girl seems to be pissed off about something.
But he keeps looking over at me. And I was on the phone with somebody who was just gabbing away. I said, okay, I need to go in the sky. I'm gonna talk to this guy And I finally hang up by the time I hang up He he and this girl there she's dragging him down the street down Shattuck Avenue in Berkeley And he keeps looking back at me and I raised my hand to say come back. He doesn't come back
Mmm, and so I was like so then I'm really I was I'm gonna tell you the full story I was so kind of dazed about all this I go I go back outside and I think, will he come back? And I thought, well, maybe he felt the same way. I'm a romantic. Maybe he'll meet me back here next Sunday at eight o'clock if he felt the same way. So I put that away. Three days later, I'm trying to buy a used computer
on Craigslist because I got a grant to help out with my writing. I was a struggling artist. I was on Craigslist for like a good hour, and then I was just staring at the home screen. And I remember reading all those Craigslist misconnections, and I thought, well, what if I wrote one of those? Oh my gosh.
So I started just reading them, and then I get to the second page, third from the top, and I see it says, Saw Yacht Settle Walgreens Berkeley. I literally jumped the fuck up and I was like, get the fuck out of here. That's me. I click on it. I almost clicked on it like I was scared. I clicked it and he described me and my faux hawk because it was 20 years ago when I had
a faux hawk. He described me to a T and said, I'm sorry, we were lost and my friend was rushing off. I hope this finds you. Apparently, he posted that just an hour before. He tried to post it three times before, but it didn't go up until like an hour before. I reached out to him by email. We agreed to meet up two days later in San Francisco at this bar named Dalva, called Dalva. I go in there. We agreed to meet up two days later in San Francisco at this bar named Dalva, called Dalva. I go in there, we have a beautiful night.
I'm trying to be a good boy. He wants me to go home with him. I'm like, ah, no, no, no, no, I'm trying, I'm trying to, you know. You know. Make him earn it a little bit more. Yeah. Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha. Or I'm trying not to be a whore. Yes, exactly. Yes, I got it. I'm with you, I understand. You understand. So I was like, you know, I'm trying to to be a whore. Yes, exactly. Yes, I got it. I'm with you. I understand. You understand. So I was like, you know,
I'm trying to practice some good behavior. So I was like, well, how about this? I'll go home with you, but we can just, let's just cuddle tonight. Cause I really, something about him I really liked. I just really liked him. And so we're laying there and I couldn't sleep. It's about four in the morning.
And I just say this quietly. I didn't think he was awake or anything. I just said, I think I love you, and you're about to change my life. And he heard me, but he didn't say anything. And so we've been together ever since. Like when I tell you God and then get this here, here's the coda to the story. There's another there's a coda. We believe we were supposed to meet two or two years before because we started to the story. There's a coda. We believe we were supposed to meet two years before
because we started to find out, I was like, oh, my agent is in the building on Gary Street in San Francisco. Oh, really? I used to work on Gary Street. I used to work for Gucci. I was a tailor at that same building. I was like, really? Oh, yeah. What floor was it on? I said, my agent was on the sixth floor. He was like, oh my God, I worked on the fifth floor. And then we both remembered this one moment. To hear the rest of the story, to find out what happened, go listen to the episode and be sure to check out the other great conversations I've had with folks like Rob Lowe, Jeremy Renner, Tyler Perry, Selma Hayek, Alec Baldwin, my own daughter Lola,
and so many more. So download my podcast, Let's Talk Off Camera with Kelly Ripa, wherever you get your podcasts. You're gonna love it. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.